mécanique d'un génocide annoncé
documentaire réalisé par le journaliste
Eric darbré ou comment au-delà d'une
terrible répression la Chine abattit une
politique de contrôle des naissances des
stérilisations de masse ou encore des
placements en orphelinat pour à terme et
radiquer les Ouigours de son territoire
un génocide annoncé déjà reconnu par une
dizaine de Parlement dans le monde ainsi
que le gouvernement des États-Unis et
maintenant que faire pour y mettre un
terme c'est évidemment toute la question
dont nous allons débattre maintenant
avec nos invités présents sur ce plateau
Eric darbré parmi nous pour commencer
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
d'investigation et c'est donc vous qui
avez réalisé l'enquête que nous venons
de voir vous travaillez sur la
répression des Ouigours depuis de très
longues années pour cela vous êtes rendu
sur place au Ching Chang plus d'une
dizaine de fois c'est un véritable tour
de force d'aller sur place
on vous doit entre autres les 8 gours un
peuple qui refuse plus de mourir une
bande dessinée illustrée par Eliott
Franck et disponible aux éditions
marabules zoomata yartine est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes d'origine
ouigo coordinatrice du Congrès mondial
des Ouigours qui cherchent à promouvoir
la démocratie des droits humanitaires et
la liberté pour les Ouigours évidemment
on a entendu parler et et mesurer le
combat qui est le vôtre dans ce
documentaire
vous avez de la famille aujourd'hui sur
place vous même vous êtes vous habitez
le Canada en tout cas c'est au Canada
que votre famille a trouvé refuge vous
aviez 10 ans à l'époque lorsque votre
famille a immigré sur place aujourd'hui
vous avez toujours une partie de votre
famille qui est au Cynthia qui subit
cette répression et même ce génocide
annoncer par ce documentaire
effectivement j'ai encore beaucoup de
monde de ma famille qui sont encore dans
la région et une trentaine de membres de
ma amis qui sont éternels dans des camps
et où qui ont disparu depuis 2017 et
depuis 2012
soit dans les camps soit disparu ont
disparu et c'est depuis 2007 que je n'ai
plus aucun contact avec les membres de
ma famille dans la région et puis
également avec nous aujourd'hui Laurence
defranou bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
au quotidien Libération vous aussi vous
enquêtez sur le sujet ouigo depuis de
longues années 7 ans réellement et puis
vous nous sortez ce livre c'est tout
chaud un remarquable les ouvrages
d'ailleurs qui s'intitule Les Ouigours
histoire d'un peuple sacrifié à se
procurer chez Tallandier un livre dans
lequel on comprend que c'est très
pression oui gourd ne date pas de ces
dernières années mais évidemment de bien
au-delà on y reviendra tout à l'heure
notamment sur la période communiste
chinoise puisque là c'est cette
répression s'est fait de plus en plus
forte depuis l'accession de Maout
setting au pouvoir en 1949 la carte bien
sûr pour situer le cygi cette région où
se trouve la majorité de la population
ouigo aujourd'hui c'est au nord-ouest de
la Chine avec oui cette frontière qui se
trouve au nord c'est le Kazakhstan
ancienne république soviétique le
Kazakhstan les Ouigours sont un peuple
turcophone dont la majorité sont de
confession musulmane certains sont de
confession chrétienne parmi ces Ouigours
et on parle d'une douzaine de millions
d'individus Ouigours avec cette
confession musulmane la majorité des
minorités sont sinisées en Chine
aujourd'hui sauf justement les Ouigours
on peut aussi parler des Tibétains et
des mongols qui revendiquent une
véritable
identité culturelle aujourd'hui en Chine
et qui ont toutes les peines du monde
évidemment à revendiquer cette
identité culturelle alors ce qui est
vraiment nouveau je trouve dans votre
formidable enquête
je crois que le mot n'est pas trop fort
après avoir vu c'est ces images et cette
démonstration vous nous avez faite c'est
que Pékin a battu une politique de
contrôle des naissances des
stérilisations de masse ou encore des
placements en orphelinat pour à terme
bel et bien et radicaux
de son territoire et là on tombe sur le
5e critère
du droit international de l'ONU qui fait
de ses faits un génocide et vous l'avez
prouvé à travers ce documentaire ça
c'est réellement nouveau ce que vous
apportez dans ce film c'est ça que vous
vouliez apporter de plus en plus de la
formidable aurait pression qui s'exerce
depuis maintenant des années sur ce club
[Musique]
en réalité c'est exactement ça j'ai
voulu apporter des preuves irréfutables
essayez de rester le plus neutre
possible et de se baser sur des faits
Adrien zen c'est technologue allemand
spécialiste des Ouigours parle d'un
génocide lent c'est exactement ça c'est
à dire que on n'est pas dans le génocide
comme Rwanda ou avec les nazis pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale où on
éradique physiquement des centaines de
milliers de personnes là
on tue par
on tue par la possibilité de régénérer
une nouvelle génération c'est à dire que
la possibilité de d'avoir des enfants
soit par des stérilisations soit par des
avortements qui peuvent aller jusqu'au
8e mois jusqu'à terme
et aussi par le fait de capter
d'arracher aux familles Ouigours leurs
enfants pour les placer dans des enfants
dans des orphelinats et leur les
transformer en bon petit chinois en bon
RAM c'est-à-dire l'ethnie principale en
Chine c'est à dire on leur apprend la
langue chinoise
l'ethnie Anne et
majoritaire en Chine en fait en Chine il
n'y a pas que des rames que des Chinois
il y a des minorités comme vous l'avez
dit dont les Ouigours et avec cette
politique très agressive à court terme
c'est à dire une ou deux générations les
Ouigours vont être de moins en moins
nombreux au sein de leur propre province
et à partir du moment où vous êtes une
minorité vous ne pouvez plus revendiquer
quoi que ce soit et c'est ça l'objectif
vous parliez des Mongols tout à l'heure
en Mongolie intérieur dans la province
chinoise les Mongols sont à peu près 5%
aujourd'hui donc à terme les Ouigours
qui étaient majoritaire comme Mao a pris
le contrôle de cette province en 49 les
Chinois les rats ne représentaient
quatre pour cent aujourd'hui ils sont
quasiment majoritaires et si rien n'est
fait dans 10 ans dans 20 ans ils seront
70 80 % et les Wiggs seront fautlorisés
politique de contrôle des naissances
stérilisation de masse ou encore
placement en orphelinat pour évidemment
éradiquer
aujourd'hui les wego vous pouvez vous
aussi apporter un témoignage de cette
politique mise en oeuvre par Pékin
aujourd'hui oui effectivement c'est je
pense que
on a déjà discuté de des politiques de
stérilisation mais au-delà de ces
politiques il y a aussi cette politique
d'assimilation que le gouvernement la
promeux aussi en éradiquant par exemple
on s'attaquant ou longue à la langue
wego qui est donc qui n'est pas
accessible au niveau de l'éducation pour
les enfants et même pour baser sur les
témoignages des anciens détenus dans ces
camps il témoigne du fait que même à
l'intérieur de ces camps quand ils sont
détenus ils ne peuvent pas utiliser la
langue c'est vraiment donc une façon de
d'attaquer notre culture notre langue
notre religion pour nous assimiler
complètement pour non seulement briser
ce lien avec avec nos valeurs
culturelles et traditionnelles mais
aussi comme
Eric l'a dit plutôt
d'empêcher qu'une future génération soit
soit créée aussi donc et c'est ce que
c'est ce qui me fait peur en fait c'est
que moi même si je pense à mes tentes à
mes cousines à mes cousins qui ne
peuvent plus être fiers de leur identité
Ouigours de leur identité culturelle et
religieuse parce que le gouvernement
de facto criminaliser ça donc moi je
sais que bon je n'ai pas de contact avec
eux mais je les imagine déjà d'ici on
soit qui sont justement ciblés par le
gouvernement par ses politiques de
stérilisation forcée ou qui se ramassent
dans des camps de travail ou dans des
camps de d'internement donc c'est pour
ça que je mène ce combat aujourd'hui
pour défendre le la voix de mon peuple
aussi et les droits fondamentaux de mon
peuple le documentaire que nous venons
de voir il apporte réellement quelque
chose de de nouveau par rapport à
d'autres documentaires que vous avez pu
voir sur le sujet pour étayer
cette thèse d'un génocide en cours sous
nos yeux en ce moment en Chine avec les
génocide
ne fait plus de doute aujourd'hui il ne
peut pas être prouvé par un par un
tribunal parce que d'une part la Chine
n'a pas reconnu la comp de la cour pénal
internationale et de l'autre pas en tant
que membre du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU mais un veto à tout en quête donc
le temps de la justice n'est pas encore
venu par contre il y a par exemple le
tribunal ouigo qui est un tribunal
populaire qui a siégé l'année dernière à
Londres qui a en question le
documentaire tombe sur le jugement rendu
par cette tribunal mais qui n'a aucune
valeur égale
des centaines de témoignages de
documents
tout à fait ça tout à fait une valeur
une valeur très importante et qui
servira beaucoup pour la suite ça permet
aux témoins de retrouver de la
documentation il y a eu aussi énormément
d'enquêtes qui ont été réalisées puisque
là encore au printemps c'est 100.000
documents qui ont fuité des archives de
la police de Sigean on a énormément de
on possède aujourd'hui toutes les
preuves il y a les discours des
dirigeants il y a des circulaires les
réglementations on a même les les modes
d'emploi des camps d'internements la
manière dont il faut parler aux familles
on a dans tous les fichiers pourquoi les
gens sont enfermés et ce qui est
incroyable c'est que moi je connaissais
la région pour être passé comme
voyageuse dans les années 90 depuis 7
ans je travaille dessus comme
journaliste j'écris beaucoup d'articles
pour Libération et en écrivant le livre
j'ai fait un près d'un an de recherche
en fait la situation est encore pire que
ce que je pensais pourtant je pensais
vraiment bien connaître puisque il y a
le travail forcé il y a la séparation
des familles
il a énormément de choses énormément de
choses et c'est une une mécanique comme
Eric a appelé son film c'est vraiment
une industrie avec un but économique et
politique pour détruire un peuple est-ce
qu'on peut dire que le président chinois
si j'ai une ping à accentué cette
politique de répression depuis qu'il est
au pouvoir depuis 2012 maintenant très
clairement c'est une politique qui est
déjà ancrée qui est assez racines depuis
plusieurs décennies mais oui depuis
l'arrivée de singing au pouvoir il a
vraiment
les choses notamment à partir de 2013
avec le lancement du projet dont vous
avez peut-être entendu parler qui
s'appelle les nouvelles routes de la
soie qui est un projet de littéralement
pharaonique d'économie et de d'influence
sur l'Eurasie et sur le reste du monde
et dans le cas de ce projet le signe
Jean donc le Turkestan oriental la
région devait originaire zone retail est
extrêmement important c'est le pivot de
l'Asie centrale depuis des siècles c'est
une région qui représente un sixième du
territoire chinois qui est frontalière
avec 8 pays qui possèdent d'énormes
ressources de en pétrole en gaz
énormément de ressources naturelles
c'est un territoire qui est quasiment
grand comme trois fois la France et les
Ouigours étant une civilisation très
ancienne c'est un peuple qui a une
grande culture qui est artistique qui
est un peu plus très résilient
pour pour exploiter ces terres pour
pouvoir pour que la Chine puisse prendre
la première place dans le monde ce que
souhaite son président il fallait
absolument que cette terre puisse être
exploitée sans réserve et donc pour cela
faire disparaître le peuple qui résiste
cette fameuse Route de la Soie qui doit
emmener
jusqu'en Europe passe déjà par le
Kazakhstan la construction est en cours
et on le revoit sur cette carte à
l'occasion il faut bien comprendre que
cette région effectivement
économiquement est devenue véritablement
stratégique pour pour Pékin on va revoir
un extrait de votre documentaire il
situe les camps dit de rééducation
concernant les Ouigours dans cette
fameuse région regardez tous ces points
sur la carte du King
ce serait des sites d'internement
les jaunes pour les camps de rééducation
les rouges pour les prisons
et les Verts pour les camps de travail
en tout il y en aurait près de 400
ça c'est ce que prétendre des experts
internationaux d'images satellites
Pékin crée au complot répète qu'il n'y a
pas de camp ou alors qu'il s'agit juste
de centres de formation professionnelle
alors ça c'est sont les camps de Guy de
rééducation sujet nier en bloc là aussi
par par Pékin aujourd'hui c'est quand
vous les avez vu de près en allant sur
place vous avez vu grandir c'est quand
et mesuré
l'extension de cette répression sur
place en fait j'ai eu
la chance l'opportunité d'en voir un en
vrai quand j'étais allé la dernière fois
que je suis allé cinquième c'était
2014-2015 et c'était à l'extérieur de
cash girl la principale principale ville
culturelle ouigo au sud et
je m'étais éloigné dans le désert et
j'étais tombé sur un camp de travail qui
déjà à l'époque
mes contacts rigoureux me disaient qu'il
avait doublé triplé de volume en
quelques années il savait exactement ce
qu'on disait c'était donc il travaillait
dans des serres agricoles
ils étaient dans avec les uniformes
bleues ou orange et
je me souviens à l'époque quand j'étais
revenu pour pour diffuser ces images on
m'avait répondu
la rédaction c'était France Télévision
m'avait répondu que c'était trop énorme
on irait pas assez de preuve il aurait
fallu que j'aille à l'intérieur c'est ça
paraissait fou ça paraissait impossible
impensable que
ça c'est en 2021 c'était l'année
dernière qui lui a appris le risque et
vous on voit ces images aussi dans votre
film parce que les risques de se
rapprocher de séquence pour les filmer
pour filmer ce qui s'y passait
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut plus
aller en Chine à cause du covid ça c'est
une première chose ensuite retournez
enquêter au thinker en étant un
Occidental je vois pas comment c'est
possible actuellement donc c'est certain
chinois certains rames qui ont le
courage d'y aller et de voler quelques
emails 50
et on a parlé un moment d'un million de
Ouigours casaque et qui agissent qui
sera enfermé dans les camps un million
c'est quand même phénoménal c'est du
jamais vu alors un million mais ça
serait le nombre de ouigo de vous
compatriotes qui serait passé dans les
camps mais certains ressortent d'autres
arrivent malheureusement il y a une
rotation dans ces camps également c'est
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que en
fait il y a plusieurs sortes de quand on
a parlé des camps de travail aussi ou
bon on ne connaît pas le nombre exact
mais bon le gouvernement chinois dans
leur version aussi des faits
ils disent que bon il y a au moins un
million de personnes qui ont passé dans
des camps de travail donc ça c'est
depuis
2018-2019 et en ce moment on sait que
avec les différents programmes de
travail forcé dont
l'implication des marques
internationales avec justement ces
programmes on connaît justement des
marques occidentaux par exemple iTunes
qui d'ailleurs s'est retiré de la région
mais aussi Adidas Puma toutes ces
marques qui sont en fait complicitées
dans ces programmes mais le chiffre 1
million ça vient de l'ONU du comité de
l'élimination de la discrimination
raciale en 2018 quand ils ont c'était
l'examen périodique sur la Chine et
après avoir justement examiner les
différents preuves qui avaient été
portées par bon les nombreuses
organisations internationales dont la
société civile ils ont conclu ou fait
que il y avait au moins un million de
Hugo et d'autres peuples turcophones qui
étaient internés
si oui à quelles conditions le
gouvernement bon ça c'est encore c'est
pas très clair parce que bon l'accès à
l'information est très limitée par
contre il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
sortis mais ça ne veut pas dire que ces
gens sont complètement libres ils vont
être surveillés de très près que ce soit
chez eux ou ailleurs et il y a aussi des
rescapés qui ont qui ont qui sont sortis
de ces camps qui ont trouvé refuge dans
d'autres pays parce que ils avaient un
passeport étranger ou ils étaient mariés
à un étranger donc ils ont pu sortir
grâce à ça mais par contre bon il y a
des gens qui rentrent qui sortent mais
après ils sont aussi remplacés par
d'autres
en plus il y a les camps donc avec
plusieurs niveaux de de répression on a
vu dans le film comme la tortue il y a
la torture il y a le viol mais il y a en
plus maintenant un autre phénomène qui
est la prison c'est et on estime qu'il y
a entre 300 et 400 000 personnes qui ont
été convaincus à des peines de prison
très lourdes puisque il s'agit souvent
de plusieurs années 15 ans 20 ans et on
a dans tous les témoins que l'on
rencontre beaucoup ont de la famille qui
a été condamné à la prison et ça peut
être par exemple 9 ans de prison pour
avoir écouté une émission religieuse
dans son taxi ça peut être 15 ans de
prison parce que la robe était trop
longue ou avoir porté une moustache en
étant fonctionnaire il faut bien penser
que ces peines de prison elles sont
incompressibles et elles sont données
avec un juste un semblant de procès
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'avocat il y a pas
moyen de se défendre et autant on peut
sortir des camps comme vous disiez
autant on ne peut pas sortir de prison
et à des enfants qui rentrent à 16 ans
qui n'en sortiront pas avant avant le
large de 30 ans puisque vous nous dites
aussi dans ce film et ça aussi c'est
prouvé c'est la surveillance de masse
dont fait l'objet de cette population
c'est à dire que grâce à des caméras
vidéos aujourd'hui
l'authentification visuelle des
individus cette population est toute
particulièrement suivie et ça c'est
depuis son domicile jusqu'à son son lieu
de travail son camp
c'est ce que la chambre à coucher du
tout
c'est à dire qu'il y a plusieurs
méthodes et ça peut paraître fou il y a
notamment cette politique qui consiste à
envoyer un référent ran au sein d'une
famille ouigourd il va vivre avec avec
les wego quelques temps pour vérifier
qu'ils vont pas prier qui n'ont pas un
Coran ou qui n'a pas un qui a des idées
un petit peu nationalistes donc ça ça
c'est très violent mais il y a aussi le
fait que moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'avait
frappé c'est que
la Chine je l'ai vu au fur et à mesure
c'est vraiment en y allant donc j'ai la
première fois j'étais en 96 et j'ai vu
progressivement l'arrivée des colons
chinois le fait qu'il détruisait les
vieux quartiers ouigo donc la culture et
qui détruisait les cimetières qui
détruisaient les mosquées et qu'il est
transformé presque je dirais en animal
de foire un petit peu comme on a fait
dans les expositions universelles dans
les années 30 moi j'ai vu à cage gare le
vieux cash gare
vous pouvez rentrer dans la partie ouigo
mais vous payez vous avez un comme si
c'était un musée vivant et vous pouvez
rentrer dans les maisons et ce sont des
vrais gens qui vivent là parce que vous
nous dites aussi que cette région et sa
concourt au processus a été colonisé par
un certain nombre de Anne justement 10
millions de Anne serait arrivé dans
cette province pour coloniser cette
région sur ordre de Pékin et je me
souviens aussi c'était au début des
années 2000 j'y étais allé quand ils
avaient ouvert la ligne de chemin de fer
jusqu'à cash gare de Pékin à cash gare
et j'avais fait tout le voyage ça avait
duré trois jours il n'y avait dans le
train dans les trains dans les wagons
que des colons RAM qui était envoyé et
c'était souvent de pauvres paysans à qui
on avait dit bon bah tu dois aller
là-bas on te donne un lopin de terre des
bonnes terres tu vas travailler tu auras
de l'argent ça sera super pour toi c'est
un petit peu comme des pionniers je
compare ça un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis avec avec les
Indiens et l'arrivée des colons on
pourra pas dire qu'on ne savait pas
après avoir vu ce film après
bon le foisonnement de preuve qui qui
aujourd'hui est sur la place publique
notamment grâce à ce tribunal de Londres
que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure une
dizaine de parlements reconnus ce
génocide en cours aujourd'hui et puis un
rapport de de l'ONU qui vient de sortir
c'était le 31 août dernier qui ne parle
pas lui de génocide en cours mais de
crimes contre l'humanité est-ce que vous
sentiment que les choses avancent et que
justement parce qu'on ne pourra pas dire
on ne savait pas
notamment du côté occidental il va
falloir réagir est-ce qu'on réagit à la
proportion dont on devrait réagir à vos
yeux aujourd'hui face à ce génocide
annoncé absolument j'ai vraiment
l'impression que les choses avancent est
très vite et depuis la sortie du rapport
le 31 août par la haute commissaire
Michel Bachelet les choses ont bougé de
façon très très rapidement beaucoup de
courage Michel Bachelet c'est elle qui
dirige cette conception mais elle a subi
de très fortes pressions de la part de
quelqu'un et c'est juste avant son
départ qu'elle a décidé de rendre public
ce rapport
13 minutes je m'en souviens parce que
j'étais à Genève à ce moment là et on
attendait tous les journalistes la
société civile on attendait ce rapport
parce qu'elle avait promis et vous êtes
déçu un peu par le contenu de rapport
déçu parce que oui je vois qu'il y a des
parties il y a des sections dans le
rapport qui ont été bon un peu on parle
pas de génocide et on parle même pas de
crime contre l'humanité on dit de
possibles crimes contre l'humanité mais
par contre je trouve que ce rapport est
très important parce qu'en fait tous les
États membres du conseil ou de l'ONU ils
attendaient ce genre de rapport du au
commissariat et donc maintenant qu'on a
ce rapport on a
on peut justement pousser vers l'action
à l'intérieur de l'ONU d'ailleurs la
semaine dernière il y avait une
résolution sur la question une
résolution qui demande à ce qu'il y a un
débat au Conseil des droits de l'homme
au mois de février par contre cette
résolution a perdu car 17 pays ont voté
pour 11 pays se sont abstenus et 19 pays
ont soutenu la Chine en se posant à
cette résolution donc
des membres donc dans ces membres du
conseil il y avait beaucoup de pays
musulmans qui se sont opposés aussi à
cette résolution donc c'est sûr qu'avec
ça on a perdu un peu d'espoir mais par
contre les choses ne s'arrêtent pas là
et on va continuer à pousser les États
membres à ce qu'ils prennent l'action et
qu'ils pensent à écrire des mécanismes
de responsabilités à l'intérieur de
l'ONU aussi mais il y a au-delà de
l'ennui d'autres façons d'agir aussi
puisque vous avez le sentiment que les
choses avancent assez vite maintenant
depuis maintenant peut-être un deux ans
sur cette question ouigo à travers cette
résolutions votées d'un certain
Parlement dont le Parlement français
c'était le 20 janvier
2022 c'est pas c'est pas si vieux disons
que beaucoup de temps a été perdu parce
que ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui on le
savait déjà en 2018 on a ça fait 4 ans
ça fait 4 ans que des gens comme je
Mouret taille comme tous les exilés les
exilés oui se battent pour faire
entendre leur voix longtemps elles sont
elles n'ont pas été entendues là je
voudrais rendre hommage aux témoins qui
parlent à visage découvert sachant que
leur famille elles payent un prix très
très lourd aux personnes qui ont vécu
des choses atroces dans les camps qui
ont le courage d'en reparler et pendant
longtemps ça a été le silence donc c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a deux ans en
libération faisait ça une sur génocide
en cours on a c'est il y a deux ans que
la France a commencé à faire entendre sa
voix mais les choses vont quand même
assez lentement donc là maintenant l'ONU
c'est une grande victoire qui a un
rapport qui officialise mais la
résolution c'était juste que le Conseil
des droits de l'homme à jeunesse ouvre
un débat sur la question au mois de
février ouvrir un débat c'était pas
grand chose malgré cela la pression de
la Chine a fait que ça a été refusé les
États-Unis aujourd'hui par exemple
mettre en place une réglementation
pour empêcher
du produit provenant de produits ou
d'être vendus sur le territoire
américain par exemple ça les États-Unis
et le Canada ont mis en place un système
qui bloque toutes les importations si on
peut parce qu'on commence à voir que il
y a quand même des produits qui passent
la Commission européenne est en train de
réfléchir à un outil équivalent parce
que le on a lancé des campagnes enfin
les militants je veux dire ont lancé des
campagnes de boycott des produits auprès
des consommateurs mais pour un
consommateur c'est extrêmement difficile
de savoir si le fil du bouton de la
chemise est un fil qui a été qui a été
filé dans une usine de singe avec des
travailleurs forcés c'est presque
impossible donc on peut pas demander aux
consommateurs de porter la
responsabilité politique c'est pour ça
qu'il faut absolument que les pays que
l'Union européenne prenne des décisions
au niveau
intergouvernementales et encore plus les
institutions internationales alors on
évoquait des marques à le textile bien
sûr parce que la culture du coton là-bas
est très très importante et représente
un intérêt comique très important voilà
les quelques entreprises qui sont dans
le collimateur du côté européen Zara
Nike Apple ça c'est pour l'électronique
Volkswagen ça c'est pour l'automobile
puis alors du côté de la France un
quatre groupes d'habillement l'espagnol
lundi d'Aix propriétaire de Zara le
français SMCP Sandro Maggi et claudi
Pierlot ce sont leurs marques et le
japonais Uniqlo l'Américain shaker sont
au cœur d'enquête ouverte par le parquet
national anti-terroriste français
aujourd'hui c'est la preuve qu'on avance
que les réglementations
internationales vont faire en sorte de
ne plus pouvoir vendre ses produits
fabriqués vous avez des vous avez des
personnalités publiques qui ont
ouvertement appelé à prendre conscience
de ce qui se passait au cinquant
des artistes donc ça ça commence à
prendre il n'y a plus mal député
européen lui il appelait boycott oui
mais ce qu'il faut aussi voir le textile
c'est une chose mais il y a aussi tout
ce qui est agriculture
on ne le sait pas forcément mais le
xinkang et je crois le deuxième
producteur mondial de la tomate et c'est
ces entreprises sont contrôlées par
l'armée c'est unique c'est à dire que si
vous prenez un ketchup en France vous
avez fortes probabilités pour que ça
provienne deux tomates du xink produit
par des wigord transformés en esclaves
ou presque et l'argent revient à des
paramilitaires ça se met la taille
pourra en parler le Bing toi c'est
unique en Chine c'est un organisme ou
limitaire font du business et en forçant
les Wiggs à travailler donc il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à dire et tout
est complètement fou ça va tellement
loin la population c'était une question
que je me posais aussi est-ce que la
population chinoise
un tant soit peu de compensation pour
les ouigoux ou suit les yeux fermés ce
qui est la politique gouvernementale
aujourd'hui alors de ce que de ce que
j'ai vu sur place
c'est que vous avez une incompréhension
pour beaucoup de Chinois qui vivent aux
signes qui ont avec une peur c'est à
dire qu'il y a quand même une propagande
d'État on leur dit attention les Wiggs
ça veut dire terrorisme ça veut dire
attentat les couteaux parce que les
couteaux sont très connus et ben ils ont
tous peur des couteaux à tel point que
si vous allez sur un marché les bouchers
ont obligation d'accrocher leur couteau
à des chaînes pour qu'ils puissent pas
éventuellement partir avec et tuer
quelqu'un il y a vraiment il y a
vraiment ça mais en dehors de du xinkyan
quand vous allez dans des grandes villes
chinoises sur la côte est beaucoup de
Chinois
éduqués disent c'est pas possible ce qui
se passe ce qui se passe avec les
Tibétains ce qui se passe avec les Wiggs
c'est inadmissible c'est c'est les
droits de l'homme c'est beaucoup de
choses donc on peut pas résumer un
milliard 400 millions d'habitants sur un
seul point mais il y a quand même
beaucoup d'incompréhension alors autre
chose qu'on peut entendre c'est que les
Américains instrumental
instrumentaliseraient pardon ce sujet
oui gourd a des fins politiques
contre la Chine c'était vrai Pompeo qui
était le secrétaire d'État de Donald
Trump qui le premier avait parlé d'un
génocide concernant les Ouigours c'est
ce que vous nous dites évidemment dans
votre documentaire est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça il y a est-ce qu'il y a
pas un risque d'instrumentalisation de
ce sujet ouigo spécifiquement par les
États-Unis dans le contexte géopolitique
qu'on connaît actuellement je pense que
c'est vraiment qu'un détail parce que en
détail oui on a encore pas du tout la
conscience de ce qui se passe là-bas
absolument pas que les États-Unis jouent
un jeu en en parlant en étant les
premiers ce n'est pas un souci parce que
il faut voir que de l'autre côté la
propagande chinoise est extrême sur la
question elle est vraiment c'est un
rouleau compresseur avec énormément
d'opérations d'influence dans les pays
démocratiques sur les réseaux sociaux
dans les médias donc c'est au contraire
c'est la Chine enfin le parti que mes
chinois qui qui nie totalement qui parle
de complot anti-chinois qui parle de
force anti-chinoise là où il y a des
faits et ce qui est assez incroyable
c'est que le gouvernement chinois
totalement la parole des oui cours parce
que cette cette idée
d'instrumentalisation c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est repris par la
propagande chinoise pour dire tout ça
n'existe pas c'est une invention
d'Amérique mais or pas du tout c'est pas
du tout une infection ni de l'Amérique
ni des Occidentaux c'est les Ouigours
eux-mêmes qui sont en première ligne et
qui dénonce c'est pas une invention
d'ONG et de force occidentale et par
rapport pour en revenir aux dégâts qui
sont faits dans la région et au travail
forcé il y a la tomate mais il y a aussi
tous les dégâts environnementaux et
c'est absolument énorme puisque
aujourd'hui le PVC par exemple qui
fabrique ce sol et ses tuyaux sont
fabriqués là-bas c'est des industries
extrêmement polluantes c'est une grande
partie du PVC mondial on a aussi des
produits clés dans les panneaux solaires
qui sont fabriqués au ciné Jong c'est
pour ça que le simple oboycott du
textile ne suffit pas et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut des prises de décision au
niveau national et international on va
finir avec vous ce sera le mot de la fin
le Congrès mondial des Ouigours j'en ai
dit un mot en vous présentant ça
représente combien de personnes
aujourd'hui et est-ce que ce congrès
mondial face aux fameux rouleau
compresseur de Pékin peut espérer faire
un contrepoids c'est sûr que c'est une
challenge mais nous on pense qu'on est à
peu près une centaine de personnes qui
qui font ce travail mais notre
communauté derrière nous la communauté
ouigo dans la diaspora on est environ un
million et on est tous là pour justement
militer et pour défendre nos droits
fondamentaux et on espère que la
communauté internationale va se joindre
à nous aussi ce sera le mot de la fin
merci vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission des Badoc
avec bien entendu votre documentaire un
formidable film qu'on pourra voir
d'ailleurs en replay bien entendu sur
LCP.fr vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag
des Badoc sur Twitter j'imagine qu'elles
seront nombreuses j'imagine aussi que
vous serez là pour réagir à ce que
seront c'est réactions merci à Selma
Sally comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission puis je vous
donne tout simplement rendez-vous pour
un prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]